you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now a lot of
the Winds have died down in most Valley
locations including the Colorado River
Valley so far to seeing light Northerly
breezes as well that is pushing it
anywhere from about three to five miles
an hour with temperatures into the 40s
and 30s for your overnight lows so
definitely feeling a lot colder earlier
into the morning into the afternoon so
far that shortwave has slowly started to
push East and that has really pushed a
lot of the Winds into our area but with
those conditions starting to calm down
we are in a good shape here as far as
mild conditions and a clearing over the
next couple of days as we look into the
East Coast again we have seen
deteriorating conditions across many
cities anywhere from at least
record-breaking snowfall heavy snow
blizzard-like conditions and of course
Gusty winds so they're not done just yet
again a couple more inches even a foot
in some locations by tomorrow the winds
however still remain light overnight and
into tomorrow morning it is the better
day tomorrow to get out there and enjoy
Recreation or if you have outdoor plans
as it won't be as Gusty as what we saw
today and even overnight we're going to
see the winds kind of push through but
still five degrees colder than what we
were seeing from last night so highs
into the 60s for tomorrow sunny
conditions even through the afternoon
and evening clear skies as we dip into
the 50s by that 8 PM hour now taking a
quick look at your highs again we have
been a lot cooler and that's because we
have been below average with
temperatures at least five or even six
degrees below our normal so 60s all the
way around for Nellis Air Force Base
Sunrise Mountain Henderson Green Valley
Mountains Edge Summerlin Centennial
Hills and Aliante for your Regional
highs a lot cooler when it comes to Reno
Tonopah and Ely but a lot warmer when it
comes to Mesquite Boulder City Pahrump
Indian Springs Sandy Valley Laughlin
Kingman and Searchlight a lot drier
condition as well as we move into the
next few days and a quick look at your
game day forecast as the Raiders take on
the Denver Broncos at Empower field into
the 40s humidity a little bit up there
at about 32 percent and a quick look at
your eight day forecast again those 60s
have been sticking around well into at
least midweek where we start to see that
warm up for Thanksgiving a lot better if
you play if you have plans or if you're
planning on uh shopping for Black Friday
and into the weekend much quieter
lighter winds again very dry as we move
into Saturday and Sunday